MALE SPEAKER: So
welcome everyone.
Welcome to this Google
Talk Authors Talk.
We're joined by Michael Horn.
I'm going to do a little
bit of introduction.
Michael Horn is the co-founder
of the Clay Christensen
Institute and author
of a couple of books
and a bunch of publications
that we're going to get into,
but the first book that
Michael and I met around
was "Disrupting Class."
I don't know if you've
had a chance to read it,
I recommend it.
Him and Clay wrote a book about
what the future of learning
looks like and how technology
was going disrupt education,
and when did that book--
MICHAEL HORN: 2008.
MALE SPEAKER: 2008.
So I read that book,
and that's what,
for me, caused me to get more
interested in how technology
can impact at least K-12.
At that time we were working
with a lot of universities.
And so I want to
talk a little bit
about that book and the
impact that book had,
but I also want to get
into the second book which
you wrote called "Blended."
I have this here.
This is not a
present for you, this
is actually a present for me.
I just did a keynote at
that Education Elements
down in San Jose and they handed
me a present, which was nice,
and so I grabbed the
present put it in my bag
and I came back to the office.
And I'm like, oh, I
wonder what this is,
and so I will open
it up for you.
I wonder what this
present could possibly be.
Oh, look.
It's "Blended" by Michael Horn.
MICHAEL HORN: It was nice
to them to give it to you.
MALE SPEAKER: It was nice
of them to give to me,
and what's interesting is
I've actually opened it up
to the first page and one
of the reviewers is me.
MICHAEL HORN: Is you.
MALE SPEAKER: I all ready read
the book and gave them a quote.
So anyways, I thought
that was funny.
So we have books in
the back for sale.
There's a couple up here that
we can give away as well,
but I wanted to get started
with this idea of thinking
about blended learning.
You hear that terminology a lot.
There's a lot of terminology
that gets tossed around,
so one, I want you to
introduce yourself,
talk a little bit more
about your background,
and then we'll get into some
questions that I have for you.
MICHAEL HORN: Sure.
First of all, thanks
for hosting me.
I appreciate it, and
thanks for all coming out.
So when we were writing
Disrupting Class starting
in 2006 after I graduated
from Harvard Business School
and was one of Clay's students,
and he literally snapped me
up and was like
we're going to write
a book using our
theories to solve
the problems in education.
I was like, that sounds cool,
and so I dove in and started
working on it with him, and the
book took two years to write.
And about midway
through, in 2007 May,
actually, we decided to start
up the Clayton Christensen
Institute.
It was originally called
[? Innocite ?] Institute,
as a think tank, nonprofit,
nonpartisan think tank
where we would be
able to just continue
to do research around these
really difficult problems
facing society.
We also have a health care
practice in some other emerging
research areas as a place just
to continue the conversation,
do research, and then
really effect change itself.
What Clay did not want was to
write an interesting book that
would gather dust
on people shelves
and would not
create real change.
We really wanted to be out there
helping make change happen,
so I now run the education
practice at the Clayton
Christensen Institute.
We have a team of just about 10
people-- a mix of researchers
and some others.
A lot of people, like myself,
who are on the road quite a bit
talking with educators,
talking with policymakers,
really taking the
research that we've
been doing using these theories
of disruptive innovation
into how we can create a
student-centered education
system, move away from
our factory model,
allow every child to realize
his or her fullest potential,
how we can actually move forward
together to make that happen.
And so I think we've been in
a dialogue with the education
community over the
last eight, nine years
really about how we
move that forward.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
And things have progressed quite
a lot since the first time you
and I met at Harvard
in 2007, 2008.
MICHAEL HORN: I think Disrupting
Class was just coming out,
and it was sort of we had this
crazy prediction in the book
that by 2019 50%
of all high school
courses would be offered
online in some way or fashion.
Most of which would
be in schools,
and everyone was like,
well, that's kind of crazy,
and it doesn't feel
so crazy anymore.
I mean, I think we're
well on the way.
Teachers are flipping
their classrooms
all over the country.
We're seeing interesting
station-rotation models
in lots of classrooms.
We're seeing schools use online
learning to connect students
to teachers that don't
live in the same zip code
for schools that don't have
access to foreign language
teachers or advanced
classes, and that's
a really exciting thing.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's
start with some definitions.
MICHAEL HORN: OK.
MALE SPEAKER: So you
have an audience here,
some that get what
we're talking about,
some that don't know
what we're talking about.
So Disrupting Class
led to this book,
which is a little more
specific, I would.
It's a little more this is
how you do it kind of thing.
So what is blended learning?
MICHAEL HORN: Let me just
give a little background.
What happened around 2009, 2010
was you had a couple schools
around the country
that people said,
we're doing "blended
learning," and they
would go to
education conferences
that Jamie and I
would often be at,
and they would get up on a panel
and start yelling at each other
that I'm blended
learning and you're not.
And it was about the stupidest
conversation you could possibly
imagine happening.
So what we did at
that time was we
looked at about 100 schools
the people said yeah,
this feels like some blended
learning is going on,
talked over 100 educators and
came up with this definition.
And so I'll give you
the technical one,
but then I'll simplify.
The technical one
has three parts.
It's any time a students
in a formal education
program in which they're
learning online at least
part of the time where they
have some element of control
over the time, the
place, the path,
and/or the pace of
learning, so the student
starts to be empowered
in this experience.
The second part is it's got to
be at least in part in a brick
and mortar location away from
home with supervision, so
schools, teachers.
And then the third part
is that the experiences
that a student enjoys they
have to be connected somehow
within a given
subject or discipline,
so what you do
offline has to connect
to the online experience.
So in other words, when I
was in school and teachers
wanted to kick me out because
I was just being distracting
or I had already mastered
something in math
and they'd say "go do Oregon
Trail," not blended learning.
Right?
The deer and the
buffalo or whatever
that I killed in
Oregon Trail had
nothing to do with
what I was learning
in the classroom
with the teacher,
so those experiences
have to be connected.
So the real thing is just to say
online learning blending itself
into our schools with teachers.
Students get some sort of
control over their learning,
and those experiences
are connected.
MALE SPEAKER: So where
are we on that path?
Like where are things today when
it comes to blended learning?
MICHAEL HORN: So blended
learning I think is exploding
way more than the quote unquote,
"ed-reform conversation"
actually popularly acknowledges.
By some estimates, 75%
of school districts
are doing some form of blended
learning across the country
right now.
And we're seeing really
interesting whole-school models
use blended learning to
literally reinvent what they do
and what the teaching and
learning experience looks
like for students and teachers
in really positive ways.
If we're being honest, a
lot of that blended learning
is not stuff that we should
get excited about also.
MALE SPEAKER: So talk a
little bit about that.
What does that mean?
MICHAEL HORN: I think actually
the original definition
that people wanted for blended
learning was the best of online
learning with the best of
brick and mortar schools,
and that's great.
That's what I hope
happens, but if we're
being honest a lot of
things that you see out
there that could
be called nothing
except blended learning are not
places we would want to send
our kids to necessarily.
They may be just sort of Night
of The Living Dead experiences
where students are clicking away
at multiple choice questions
on a computer, a
teacher is there,
but they're filing their
nails because they feel
like they've been replaced.
This isn't a good experience,
and if we're being honest
there's a fair amount
of that going on.
And so my sense of where
we are in this pathway
is blended learning is happening
whether we like it or not.
The exciting thing
about it is the ability
to personalize an education for
every student's distinct needs
so that they can
find their passion
and realize their
potential, but we
have to really be pushing
people in that quality piece
now, and educating people
about the possibilities
that it delivers
for the first time
in human history for
every single child,
but we're not there yet.
MALE SPEAKER: So
talk about the role
of technology in this world.
Where were we, what do you
see, and what's needed?
So the magic
question-- where do you
see technology's role in this
blended learning environment?
MICHAEL HORN: Maybe
it's useful to talk
about this as a trajectory, but
where I think online learning
and technology first
started in this environment
was really whole
class experiences that
were delivered
online where you'd
write an entire curriculum
for a particular course
and students would jump
on and have a teacher
sort of facilitating
and tutoring
alongside that experience, but
really the course curriculum
was all in this package
content from one vendor.
Where I think we've
started to evolve to
is that teachers in
schools are actually
using a variety of content
in learning experiences
from online from a
variety of sources
to custom configure
that learning experience
for students.
And so you might see a classroom
in Los Angeles, California
at a school serving kindergarten
through fifth grade students
where students are
rotating through a variety
of experiences, one of which
is that online learning.
Some kids will be
working on a program
like ST Math learning math
through a visual way of playing
a game.
Other students will
be doing DreamBox
learning-- very different way.
And still, other
students might be
on Khan Academy
learning math depending
on their particular
point in their learning
and what they're
trying to work on.
And I think the big
challenge that we're now
facing right now for teachers
on the ground is great,
there's all these options,
there's a lot of free content
out there on the web that I
can use and so forth and then
connect my students with
different learning experiences,
and all these things are
spitting of data for me
that I can figure out
where my students are
and help them navigate
different pathways.
Holy cow.
How do I get these software
programs to really talk
to each other in a
way that's meaningful
so I can do something
actionable for students.
And I think that's where we are
right now where there haven't
really been platforms
that have emerged yet
that have helped make sense
of this very fragmented world
that's emerging.
MALE SPEAKER: So
you're at Google.
We have various tools.
From an education perspective we
have Google Apps for education,
we have Classroom, we have
all these different things.
MICHAEL HORN: And happy
birthday Classroom.
Right?
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
A couple of days ago.
So what has the impact
from your perspective,
working with those schools,
what have you seen,
how have you seen our tools
been used in education?
MICHAEL HORN: I think you're
seeing Google's impact all
over the place right now in
education in a couple ways.
One, so in some of
the environments
that are not blended
learning by our definition,
but you're still starting people
experiment with technology.
You're seeing Google Apps be
used sort of as that entry
level what can we start to do
with technology, what can we
start to pull in, what
can we start to create?
And so very clearly disrupting
a lot of the software makers
that were there before in
a lot of these productivity
tools and Google
Apps coming in there.
What I think then happens once
you move to a blended learning
environment is you
start to say, how can we
use time very differently?
So we may want students
engaging in direct instruction
in a particular
software program,
but now we can
start to use Google
Apps for the project
based learning,
coordinate whole
aspects of learning
in some pretty exciting ways.
I think you're seeing
teachers use those pathways
through a variety of Google
Apps in pretty neat ways,
and I don't know many schools
that don't use Google Apps when
they get into blended learning.
The other part that I
think is really exciting
that we talk about a fair amount
is the Chromebook world, which
from my perspective,
Chromebooks make the most
sense for the majority
of schools getting
into this blended learning
game because they're not just
consumption devices, they
are also creation devices,
and I think that's
what separates them
from a lot of the
tablets that have
gotten dumped on the market.
And then the price point I
think is extremely attractive,
and then the way you can
manage them from the cloud
is something that
I think schools
have found extraordinarily
useful in terms
of managing devices
that otherwise get
into problems in other places.
One other quick thing-- I
think your team in particular
has done a good job of one
other thing, which is not
to go into schools
and say, "all right,
here are you Chromebooks.
Go have fun."
You've actually
helped people think
through what's the design
process that you want
to go through, what are you
actually trying to solve,
and then how can our
technology-- huge range of it,
right-- be marshalled to
help you solve these problems
for teachers and students.
And from my perspective, that's
what every school and district
ought to be doing is a
much more grounds up,
what are we trying
to do together,
and then technology
and service of that
rather than just
layer on technology.
MALE SPEAKER: So by the
way, in a couple minutes
I'm going to ask you
guys for question,
so think of your questions.
We want to make sure that we
ask Michael some questions.
The one question I have for
your around blended learning
is where does it usually start.
Does it start in kindergarten?
Does it start in third grade?
Where do you see the peak of
blended learning take off?
MICHAEL HORN: It's a great
question-- all over the place.
And I think for a lot
of district schools
it started in high
school, particularly
in these areas of
non-consumption,
in our language, where the
alternative is nothing at all.
And I don't think people
realize this-- 50%
of our high schools in this
country don't offer calculus.
37% of our high schools
do not offer physics.
If you're in the
state of Georgia,
there's 440 high
schools roughly--
there are 88 certified physics
teachers in the entire state.
OK?
So we can talk
about stem problems
or whatever else all
we want, like we've
got to get real about that.
So high schools literally
need to use online learning
in their schools
to connect students
to highly qualified teachers and
create very different learning
experiences from
that which has come
before-- really important
part where a lot of this
has started.
I think in elementary school
you're seeing it much more
in core classes--
math and reading,
and in terms of what
grade level it's literally
all over the map.
You have great
examples all over.
I think the one thing you'd say
is if you're in kindergarten
I don't want my kid on the
screen for three hours a day.
I'm comfortable
with 20, 30 minutes,
and then if you're
in fifth grade
you could do a little
bit more than that.
So it's a continuum, it does not
look the same in any one place.
MALE SPEAKER: By the way, we
both have little, tiny babies.
Yours are seven,
eight months old.
Mine is eight months
old, about the same time.
Right now technology is
about eating it, right?
I posted a picture
of my seven-month-old
using YouTube for YouTube
for kids by eating it.
MICHAEL HORN: So I have twins,
so my problems are times two,
I suppose, but one of them
was on the bed the other day
and trying to
literally crawl-- she
was crawling over me
to get at my phone.
MALE SPEAKER: They
have a screen thing.
MICHAEL HORN: They
have a screen thing
and literally all
she wanted to do
was like go on a suicide
mission off the bed
to try to get to this phone,
and it was like, oh my God.
MALE SPEAKER: It's like a
squirrel thing from "Up."
MICHAEL HORN: Yes, exactly.
Squirrel.
MALE SPEAKER: So you didn't
even mention computer science
and the fact that
most states don't even
offer computer science, and
how do we do computer science--
MICHAEL HORN: Huge
area, and I think
that's why you're seeing
an explosion of companies
and tools and nonprofits
around coding,
and there's been huge
campaigns around that.
Really synergistic way to
introduce blended learning
into a community.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
So a lot of what you're talking
about is here, based in the US.
Do you work with school
districts across the world?
And you mentioned the shortage
of classes and teachers
who teach specific classes.
You think about a
country like India
where they are short 1.4
million teachers, right?
Whatever number you want to
use, but it's more than five.
So what does blended
learning look
like on the
international scale, what
are you seeing in that space?
MICHAEL HORN: I think the
models are looking and will
look very different
from what they
look like in the US for
a variety of reasons.
I think mobile will be a
much bigger deal as you
go into emerging countries.
I also think the
disruptive innovations will
be much bigger that they
create, and the reason
I say that is if you think
about disruptive innovation
theory-- I'm making
an assumption everyone
has some idea that
here-- but it starts
in these areas of
non-consumption
where the alternative
is truly nothing at all.
In the United States we have
full consumption of schooling.
Basically everyone has
a schooling option.
You have non-consumption
of classes.
In some of these emerging
markets in developing countries
you don't have schools, or
you don't have schools that
are real options in any event.
Teachers don't show
up or they're too far
for girls and boys to travel.
So the opportunity to
bring these things and very
new solutions into
communities themselves I think
is an unbelievable
opportunity for innovation
and it has obviously a
whole set of barriers, but--
MALE SPEAKER: What are
some of those barriers?
MICHAEL HORN: Well, obviously
infrastructure and access
is one.
I think helping the communities
know how to use it is another,
and thinking about it not from
a US-centric point of view.
I think we have a
certain attitude that it
has to be sort of
a tablet or laptop
or to be quote
unquote, "good enough."
In these places
like an SMS program
that helps feed the
teacher ideas for projects
to do as students could be
the right learning modality
in any given day.
I think we have to reset
our expectations on that.
I spent a fair amount of
time in Vietnam looking
at this last year, and if
you look at the rural areas
there's actually
lots of cellphones,
but creating relevant
curriculum for those contexts
you can't just
take our curriculum
and like port it into a
different place and say,
there we've solved it.
So there's a whole bunch
of cultural, language,
and circumstantial, like
actually making it relevant.
I'll give a very
concrete example.
In the North of Vietnam there's
a lot of tribal communities
that are cut off from the rest
of the Vietnamese language
and culture and so forth.
Vietnam basically
makes them attend
the nationalized
schools, if you will,
that teach curriculum
that's totally
irrelevant for their
lives and so forth.
If they can learn
English though they
can get ahead big time in the
tourism worlds and so forth.
So basically all
these kids drop out
of these government run
schools by the first grade.
Don't attend, tend to
live in these very small--
they laugh at us if you
and I were to walk in,
because we don't
fit in their houses.
But super useful if they can get
access to English in a way that
makes sense for their
context and teaches them
things that help explain in
their environment to people
like me coming through.
People haven't
grappled with that.
MALE SPEAKER: So I want to
turn it over to the audience,
but before I do that and as
they think about the questions
that they want to ask,
the question I want to ask
is around professional
development.
What does professional
development look
like in a blended
learning environment,
what are we doing right,
what are we not doing right?
MICHAEL HORN: Well,
let's start with this,
which is the role of
the teacher dramatically
changes in these blended
learning environments.
And so the first thing
to say right is teachers
are absolutely critical still,
but they look different.
They're not delivering a
lecture or a lesson plan
to a class of 30
students who they're
assuming are all on the
same place and same learning
pathway.
That doesn't make any
sense, because now they're
all progressing
in different ways,
working on different projects,
and so a teacher is serving
as a tutor, a mentor,
a designer of projects,
and assessors or
evaluator of learning.
Very different sets of things,
maybe even a non-academic coach
In many cases dealing with
all the emotional and health
problems that come up in
the way and block people
from learning all the
time that we don't tend
to talk about in this country.
It's a very different
role, and so
if you talk to a
blended learning teacher
you say how much of
your teacher preparation
program or professional
development trained you
for what you're doing now, and
they'll typically say something
like I don't know, 5% of
what I learned trained me
for 95% of my job, and
95% of what I learned
is maybe relevant
for 5% of my job.
So that's really difficult
that we're putting teachers
in these circumstances.
The good news, I think, is
that teachers are smart people
and they over time start
to figure these things out.
The bad news is like, why
do we put them through that,
and can't we do a better
job supporting them?
And so my sense is that,
a, the preparation programs
will have to change
dramatically.
Tom Arnett on our team is
doing a lot of research,
he's actually speaking about
it at the EdElements Summit
today on how do we moved to
new preparation programs.
And then I think the
professional development
should be much more personalized
for different teacher needs,
just as we would personalize
professional development
for students, and much
more just in time.
So rather than some guy
like me writes a book,
shows up at a school district
three, four times a year
and does professional
development
that's only tangentially related
to what the teachers are doing
in the classroom that they
get access to just in time
professional development
every single day
with whatever
challenges that they're
facing that are very tailored
to what they're doing.
I think Summit Public
Schools in the Bay Area
probably is the closest to
getting this right today
with the professional
development
that they do for teachers
in a very personalized
way on their platform.
MALE SPEAKER: So the
last thing, because I
have 100 questions for you,
but you and I have talked
about this idea around
making sure that none of us
are contributing to making
old education or bad education
faster and more efficient.
What do you see happening
in that space, what could
we all do better in that space?
MICHAEL HORN: I'm worried.
I think if we hit 50% 2019 and
we've replicated the factory
model online.
What's today?
May 7.
You were born in the
year the lamb, therefore
we're all doing
double-digit addition,
like we've really failed.
And I think there's
a big risk of that,
so I think a couple
things we have to do.
One is really talk about
the why of this movement,
and then talk about what
it can unleash, and make
it accessible to--
I think sometimes we
do ourselves a disservice when
we show the summits of the High
Tech Highs, because it
feels like so out of grasp.
I think we have to make it
a little bit more accessible
for the parental and teacher
communities around the country.
The second thing I think we need
to do is think about policy,
and the environment
into which we're
making these transformations,
and maybe kick it
to you for your story
about the architecture.
MALE SPEAKER: Oh, yeah.
We were talking before
the talk today--
the idea that when you look at
a building, beautiful architect
of a building, you
look at the building
and you don't say I wonder
what kind of wrench they used.
Right?
Or what kind of drill they used.
You talk about the actual
outcome of that building,
and so our students are
that architect, the outcome.
MICHAEL HORN: Yeah,
and I think the policy
is concerned about the tools.
Policy mandates the
number of minutes
you have to sit in seats.
It actually literally
funds schools
based on the number of
minutes students are in seats,
so if you step back
from it for a moment
you say we've been
measuring the wrong end
of the student for 100
years, but we continue do so.
Restrictions around
class size even,
what classes look like, a lot
of the facility restrictions.
We could imagine a much
different education system.
A lot of the teacher-eval
policies coming on right
now are counterproductive.
They're very
consumed with inputs.
We need to be
looking at not just
student outcomes at a
point in time on a test,
but actually the growth
of students over time
at an individual level.
I think the other thing that
we do unfairly right now is--
and I'm a big believer
in the intentions
behind the
accountability movement,
and the power of standards
if we do it right-- but right
now if students
are in fifth grade
and they come in at a
second grade reading level,
we test them at the end of
year with a fifth grade test
and say they're now reading
at a fourth grade level.
A teacher doesn't get
any credit for that.
We don't get we don't see that.
That's ridiculous.
Like that teacher just
made two years of progress
with that student,
that's amazing.
We don't focus on that.
We don't talk about
that, and so we
need to do a much better
job of thinking about what
does assessment mean.
What are the rich
kinds of assessments
we actually want to
see, and how do we
evaluate those in a
fair and equitable way.
MALE SPEAKER: I
got a mic up here.
I want to turn it over
to whoever has questions.
Of course you guys
have questions.
We'll start up
here in front row,
and as they are asking
questions the last question
I'm going to ask you is what
can we, Google, do, and so
just think about that
question and I'll
ask you before we wrap up.
AUDIENCE: So I work on a product
here at Google Course Builder,
and one of the things
that we worry about
is content delivery to
the other five billion,
and that mostly looks like small
devices, cell phones or maybe
tablets.
How do you do content delivery
on a small device effectively?
MICHAEL HORN: And this
goes to the conversation
we were having about not
applying the US standards
of what we think
good content has
to be is I think we have to
take a very different mindset
and understand how they're
getting content today,
or not getting content, and then
what is a good enough state,
and then what sets it
on a trajectory that
starts to improve.
And I think that's
tough sometimes
when we're talking about
improving social sectors,
as like something that's
not perfect but good enough,
but that's the coin in the
realm with disruption, which
is like when the Google
search engine started
it doesn't do all that it did
now, but it was good enough.
It was good enough
to get it started
and change the way we view
information and content,
and so I think getting a
good enough perspective is
the first thing.
The second thing I
think-- this is probably
somewhat controversial, but
I think in Silicon Valley
is way too bullish
right now on video.
Video is useful in certain
learning circumstances,
but it's actually for many
tasks a very inefficient way
of learning.
Ironic, as I'm
being videoed, and I
think we need to
think about what
are short chunks of information
that cause people to interact
a lot in these modalities
that actually create
lots of opportunities
for interaction
to build motivation,
and you actually
learn through your interaction
and the explanation afterwards,
not necessarily the content
that was delivered at you,
because that makes you a
much more active learner.
So--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
MICHAEL HORN: Yeah, video push.
Yeah, exactly,
where we think that
a 10 minute video is the best
way to consume and understand
content.
I actually think the learning
sciences disagree strongly
that, and there are certain
contexts where video
is extraordinarily
useful at illuminating
a certain thing that can only
be understood through video
or being transported there,
but actually short tech space
things that cause you to
respond and talk about things
and be an active
learner, which are well
suited to some of these
small devices I think
can actually be a much more
powerful medium in many cases.
MALE SPEAKER: You and I have
often talked about this,
and you mentioned
at the beginning
of the answer of good enough.
I think the biggest problem in
education from my perspective
is this idea that there's some
magic model out there that you
have to find, and that
you just have to do that.
The title my keynote is
Iteration and Innovation.
Like how do we create a culture
of iteration and innovation
that there is no school,
it's a constant change.
MICHAEL HORN: So "Blended" is
basically a design guide for--
MALE SPEAKER: By the way, this
is a "How To" book, right?
MICHAEL HORN: Yeah, I mean
it really is a field guide,
but it doesn't say
this is the answer.
It actually gives a process
for you to create a constantly
a iterating,
improving innovation,
and I think the real messages
is like, you know what,
even if you nailed it
for today circumstance,
in 10 years from now societies
going to change some more
and we need to keep evolving
and innovating with that.
So how do you do
that, and I think
we need to stop
thinking of school
as like a finished product
that OK, that's it,
let's all do that.
MALE SPEAKER: Exactly.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So you mentioned that we
need a platform to emerge
to kind of pull some
of the student data
together in order for blended
learning to really take off.
How do you balance
that with what
feels like a tightening in
student data privacy laws?
MICHAEL HORN: Great question,
and the million dollar
one that Julia
Freeland on my team
is starting to think about,
but I haven't done enough
thought on.
I think that we do need to
create a different narrative
around why data
matters in education,
because it's been a very
defensive conversation
at this point.
We've just been
talking about of course
data shouldn't be used to sell
products to kids and stuff
like that.
Rather than making the case
for like why you as a parent
you actually want your teacher
and student having access
to data, and not just
like their data, right?
Because it's an incredibly
empowering thing when
you as a student-- let's talk
about that for a moment--
can say like, I
didn't get that right,
and I can do something
about it to improve myself.
That's a deeply
motivating thing.
We haven't done a good
job of articulating
that in a way that actually is
a positive case that it make
sense and people can rally
around, so I think actually
the biggest thing is play
some offense on this issue
and start to show
scenarios about why parents
and teachers would want
this, and what it can do
for learning, as opposed
to well yeah, of course
we don't mean that in
sort of a defensive crouch
where we've been.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
irony is that we accept,
the parents accept-- and I'm a
parent, but I accept the data
or we accept the data that's
the assessment-based data that's
six months old or a
year old, but we're not
looking at the
performance-based data, which
is the critical stuff.
That's the stuff that we really.
MICHAEL HORN: And I think
this whole opt-out world
right now that's
happening, we need
to be carving a
consensus of assessment
can be a much more seamless
light touch thing that
is happening constantly in
the background, and even
objective ways.
And yeah, it can be a
lighter footprint that
is truly individually
focused and helping inform
and gives us an accountability
picture, transparency,
but is really about
the learning itself
and people can get behind that.
The assessments aren't
there today for that,
but helping parents
understand we're on a road
to that and not to neglect kids
in low-income circumstances
who might not have the
same sort of advantages
where and why
we're on a journey.
But I also think it would help
to articulate it as a journey
and not say that the
assessments we have
today we should be happy about.
AUDIENCE: I just want to add to
that, because this is actually
what I've been looking for.
And people always think the
Department of Ed has tons
of money, we don't.
And I think Google
may be in a place
to really help with this is.
I've been talking to
a number of people
about trying to figure out
some kind of short infographic
or something that
actually leads parents
like really clear articulating
this is good use of data.
It's almost like the
old video of like how
a bill becomes-- you know
like "It's Only a Bill?"
MICHAEL HORN: Mr. Bill.
AUDIENCE: You go through and
it's sort of like literally
where the data goes, like
this is a good place,
this is an OK place, you
can protect this data
even though you're using the
data to make the back end look.
And I really do think
some clear definitions
and literally some
visualization of what
that looks like would help
the whole conversation
work a little bit better.
MALE SPEAKER: Right.
But also to Michael's
point about like creating
some language around
what we're doing,
we do it in sports, right?
We have performance
based data in sports.
A baseball player comes up to
bat, he bats 276 on Thursdays.
When it's raining he bats 234.
Right?
We have that level
of performance data.
He doesn't take a test
at the end of the season
to find out how much he
knows about baseball, right?
So it's a different philosophy.
We need to get better--
MICHAEL HORN: We need
to give better scenarios
to help people shoot for that
also in terms of the developer
community, or people who
are building off the Google
platforms that you all have.
Inspiring I think is
what we need to do.
But I agree with
what you said, and I
think just the quick
add-on is-- and I'm
blanking on what I
was going to say now,
but just helping districts
adopt in a responsible way
would also be really useful.
And I think if a
place like Google
could rally some of the
other hardware-makers
to this game and others, like
sort of like a pledge of we
will have this sort of
behavior as we come in.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
we signed a pledge.
MICHAEL HORN: You have, yeah.
But I mean literally making that
known among districts of like,
I won't work with
you Mr. PC, unless I
know you've committed to this.
And maybe not just around
data, quite frankly,
but I won't sell you
one-to-one laptops
unless I've seen
some sort of design
that you've gone through
about why you would use them.
MALE SPEAKER: Now you're
pushing your luck.
MICHAEL HORN: But you're the
only game that I can push it.
AUDIENCE: I have two
questions and I'm
going to make them
sound like one so Jamie
doesn't yell at me.
MALE SPEAKER: No, you
can ask two questions.
That's fine.
You're Tracy.
AUDIENCE: OK, but they're
both around sort of philosophy
of the future of education.
I think fundamentally we
all who work on education
feel strongly about
personalized learning.
Clearly that's a
huge place where
technology can be an enabler.
It's very exciting.
It makes a ton of sense.
We also talked a lot about
project-based learning as a way
that kids will
interact more with what
they're being presented with.
So I'm curious on two things.
I'd love your thoughts
on like best practices
around personalized learning.
What do you think of
things like AltSchool--
some of the folks who are
trying to solve that problem
from a technology perspective.
And then do you feel like a
focus on project-based learning
is warranted, or is
there some other future
that you imagine that
sort of around the curve
that maybe we're not seeing
that's the next big thing or is
there a more generalized
way to think about it?
MICHAEL HORN: So I'm
really glad, first of all,
that you separated those
two terms, because I think
a lot of people they
hear student-centered or
personalized and automatically
say that's 100% project based,
and I don't think
that's actually true.
Right?
You don't learn to shoot
free throws in basketball
in the game, you actually
have to practice them
and it's not always
the most exciting.
But you also play the game
to understand the context
and build motivation
and apply, right?
So there are give and
takes I think in education,
and we've had this unbelievably
broken dialogue between "isms."
You're either core knowledge
versus project-based learning,
and it's like well,
hold on, I think
there's actually value
in both and what's
the right mix of things.
And it turns out you do
need knowledge to know
what to Google in learning,
and so that still is important,
but so it too is applying it.
So the way I think about
blended learning is it offers us
the opportunity to
change the use of time
so that we can break these
things that have been
false dichotomies,
but I think has
been very difficult like
in the time-based way
we view schools to
actually do both.
There's some great
project-based learning schools
that are out there, but
there's some really bad ones
where kids are doing
superficial things
and they don't really understand
fundamentals underneath it,
and so this is really the
opportunity to split that.
So I'll answer that
question more directly now
with just that preface, because
if you look at Summit Public
Schools they are one that I
think is getting the mix right.
On personalized
learning, really excited
about a number of the
potentials coming around.
I think there's a bit of
a split in the field right
now around adaptive learning
engines versus a more
playlist approach to the world.
It's not clear to me what
is going to win there.
I actually think
there's value in both,
and I think the adaptive
learning is a way more complex
problem than most people believe
it is because yes, you're
getting way more
data from students,
but they're also
sending a lot of signals
based on what they ate
that morning that is
very difficult to account for.
So I think super
interesting place,
really interested in what
Newton is doing, really
interested in what
AltSchool is doing,
really interested in what Khan
Academy is doing in that world
as well, so lots of
interesting experiments.
Really interested
also simultaneously
on the playlist approach,
like Summit Public Schools
is doing with their
personalized learning plan
where there's 10 different
ways to learn a given standard
and actually students
get to navigate and make
those choices.
And again, I think adaptability
versus assignability or choice
will end up being a false
dichotomy in the future as
well.
I think there will be a mix
where just like Google helps
nudge me, it doesn't
actually make decisions
for me as I'm doing things.
I think there will be something
with a trade-off and younger
students you may give more
help making those decisions
and do gradual
release as they get
older so they become lifelong
learners and really owners
of that learning experience.
In terms of AltSchool
specifically,
for those that don't know
just raised $100 million,
I went to college with Max,
so I know him reasonably well.
I'm really interest to see
what actually comes out of it.
I think at minimum it'll be a
really exciting school network
itself that helps
to disrupt a lot
of independent or private
schools around the country.
I think this micro-school
network is very exciting
that's emerging.
I think we might in
the future sort of
see the Airbnb schooling
that allows for pop-ups
and allows for very
different communities
to form depending on
the day or what subject
you're learning in the future.
I'm skeptical of taking a
platform developed very deeply
in a particular school setting
with a very particular model,
and then just thinking, oh we'll
just give that to a district
and it will work and
it will save them
30% because they don't need
this administrative overhead
or something like that.
I'm very skeptical of that,
because it's interdependent,
and I think that's
important right now.
We're not ready
for modular stage,
but I don't think it'll
just pour it over.
Project-based learning-- I think
it's a deeper understanding
of what projects can be and how
they interact with knowledge
and things like that will
come down the pipeline,
if that make sense.
And I also think if we can
start to actually tie them
into real world problems
increasingly that's maybe
the next frontier where we
start to bring employers
and experts in social capital
into these communities in very
different ways from the ways
we've done traditionally.
I think Google
can be a big part.
AUDIENCE: I wonder
if it's almost better
to think about intrinsic
versus extrinsic motivation
as what you're trying to create
out of that system, as opposed
to actually having
it be project-based.
MICHAEL HORN: I
think that's right.
I mean, it creates an excitement
and desire to know more,
and also I didn't
know what engineering
was until I was like
a junior in college,
so a much better sense of
what real jobs and careers are
out there.
MALE SPEAKER: We
started with start
the conversation by trying to
find blended learning, we can
do the same thing with
personal learning,
whether it's personal,
personalised, individualised or
project-based learning and
what project-based learning is.
I often get push-back
from students.
I was speaking at ASU
with Dr. Crow in a class
and one of the
student says, I don't
want to do
project-based learning,
because when I did project-based
learning when I was in school
I was the one who
did all the work.
And I'm like, you
didn't do project-based.
You did one paper
that was split up
by five people that could
have been done by one person.
That's not
project-based learning.
So a lot of it has to do with
the definitions that we use.
MICHAEL HORN: I agree with that.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah?
Oh, we've got lots of questions.
I want to make sure
I get them all in.
AUDIENCE: Can you
talk a little bit
about as we think
about the achievement
gap, the role of technology
and helping to close it
or potentially the risk that
it actually could worsen it,
because we talked
about the ability
to improve education
outcomes overall,
but with the worst schools--
MICHAEL HORN: Yeah,
totally good question.
So I think the first
thing to acknowledge
is that higher income kids are
already going to get access
to these tools, and so
it's incumbent upon schools
to do these things
for low income,
because otherwise that
achievement gap will really
widen.
I think the other thing
personalized learning does
is a lot of students
fall further and further
behind because lessons
continue to move
and you actually have a deep
fundamental misconception
or misunderstanding
much earlier.
And if you can actually
change that, so go back
in their learning if you will,
and change that, it actually
unlocks a much faster
trajectory then
we give credit to
low income students
typically for being able to
do, which you can give that
any set of names, but I think
of it as education malpractice
often.
So I think the small
evidence we have actually is
that unleashing this actually
causes these people we thought
of as slow learners or
low on the achievement gap
or whatever to actually soar
much faster than we thought
was possible.
I do think it will
create gaps, because it
will allow the high-flyers to
go much further and faster.
I think the hope is
that income is not
the predictor of those
gaps, and that it's
based on other factors.
MALE SPEAKER: And the
number haven't changed,
so if you make more
than $75,000 a year
there's a 95% chance you
have internet access at home
and the technology at home.
If you make less
than $30,00 it's
like 45% of whatever
that number is
so you know that that
gap is already there,
and it is possible
to make that worse.
Rich school districts
have technology,
poor school districts don't.
That's just the facts.
MICHAEL HORN: And we
also know that how
students in those areas today
use this technology is not
actually often positive,
because they don't have
a community, teachers, parents
around them helping guide them
in a productive way
on that journey,
so there's plenty
of studies the just
show the introduction
of technology--
doesn't do anything.
So we have to be very deliberate
about designing coherent models
for the circumstances.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You talked a little
bit about over reliance
on video, which kind
of made me think
do you think overall in
the blended learning space
that we're not
leveraging enough of what
we know about behavioral
and educational psychology?
Do you know, are there
any examples of programs
you think are doing
that particularly well,
or are there gaps
in the research
that you think we're
not drawing upon enough?
MICHAEL HORN: Yes.
We are totally
ignoring that field.
The developers,
like if you haven't
heard of Richard
Mayer and his work
on e-learning and the
science instruction
like you are just starting
behind the eight ball.
Not to say that there won't be
exceptions to that research.
I think a lot of
education research
is pretty deeply flawed
because it looks at the average
as opposed to be
anomalies and comes up
with a circumstance-based
theory,
but there's a lot
of good research
that can boost you
up dramatically
to start with, and then
explore anomalies from there.
And I think most people are
totally ignoring what we know.
There are a few good
providers out there based
on different facets of it.
I think ST Math
does it pretty well.
But there's a huge
gap in that right now.
MALE SPEAKER: And
not just that, we
have 40 years of
research and evidence
about like what really good
learning can look like,
and I think technology can
help us actually implement
a lot of that.
We have just been ignoring
it, or the positive way
of saying it is that
technology hasn't
been ready to use to implement.
I'm the glass half-full
guy, he's the empty glass.
MICHAEL HORN: Just there.
AUDIENCE: Back to your
question about data and sharing
that daily, how can you avoid
the stress that that can cause
on a family, especially
like at a high school level
when you're seeing daily grade
reports and daily progress
reports and the
stress of the parents
coming down on the students
for that, and in some ways
it seems like there's too
much information that is not
being dealt with between
student and teacher
before it's dealt with
between student and family.
MICHAEL HORN: Yeah,
so I'm not sure
the connection to parents
that should be made there.
I think that's probably another
design choice that should
be made within the schools.
I more meant with
in terms of what
it can do for teachers
to more effectively work
with students and students to
be more effectively motivated.
One thing we also know from
the research that people ignore
is that data is not necessarily
a motivating force in learning,
so let me explain.
If you give a student data
and they have no ability
to do anything with
that data, it just
says you got a
70%, that is deeply
demotivating to learning.
If it says, you
haven't mastered this,
and this is the particular area,
now go back and work again,
so what we call a
competency-based or
mastery-based learning
system then data
is deeply motivating as you
can do something with it.
And so that's the type of
data and the type of system
that we actually need to use
it in to empower learners
to understand where they
are going in their learning,
and so that they can
constantly be using it
to improve with their teachers.
How that works with
parents, I think
that's a community by community
decision that make sense,
but it also changes.
It's sort of like think of
it as a, b, or try again.
We're going to eliminate letter
grades as we know if we really
get this right,
because we really
ought to be mastering
something before you move on.
Sal Khan gives the great analogy
like you wouldn't be like,
we're building a house,
well, I got 80% of it right,
so let's move on to
the second floor now.
But that's how we
do it in schools,
and those gaps create huge
problems later in learning.
MALE SPEAKER: You don't
even need a house.
In our own work world,
if some one on a team
hands one of us the
strategy and we're like,
oh, this is about a C
plus, next assignment.
No, you iterate.
You change it.
AUDIENCE: So I think in
education over the last 50,
60 years the publishers have
really been the big players,
and as they're
grappling with this move
I think you see the pitfall
oftentimes of a textbook just
being digitized.
MICHAEL HORN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
curious if you were
to jump in as the
CEO of a Pearson
or an H&H or McGraw
Hill, where would you
take that digital content
strategy as a whole?
MICHAEL HORN: Oh, God.
MALE SPEAKER: Why couldn't
you ask that like an hour ago?
MICHAEL HORN: Talk about
jobs I wouldn't want.
OK.
So I think the lessons
of destruction are clear.
When you want to be the
one to disrupt yourself,
you can't do it within
your current organization.
You have to set up an
autonomous organization that has
the freedom to rethink
everything and can ask
the parent for things, but
cannot be commanded to do
things by the parent,
and so if I were them,
I would set up truly autonomous
business models that could say
yes, we want to draw
upon your rich resources,
but we're not going to be told
how we're going to use them
or deploy them and we are
going to have very different
processes and priorities
inside to do this.
And that's how I
would approach it.
I also think our policymakers
would do us a great service
if they stopped talking
about digital textbooks,
because that's not what
we're trying to do here.
MALE SPEAKER: So speaking
of digital textbooks
I want you to think
about that question
I was going to ask you, I
also want to plug your book.
If you are like my kid who
cannot read a digital book,
he actually likes the hardcover
books there's hardcover books
back there.
You can get it on Amazon, Google
Play, and other places as well.
So last question for
you before we wrap up.
What can we do to help?
MICHAEL HORN: So I think Google
can do a number of things.
I think one, the continued
improvement of the Chromebook
platform at a price that
schools can embrace.
Huge, because it
takes the equipment
question off the table and
hopefully shifts the question
to the learning question.
And I've always
felt that with you
is that you ask the
learning question first
is the other really big thing.
And I know you said the
pledge won't happen,
but I think the more we
can get a conversation
around the learning
questions we're
trying to solve first,
really important.
And then a lot of the apps
and the suite of tools
that you can bring to bear,
regardless of platform
quite frankly, but
showing again those things
in service of the learning
goals just tremendous,
but really make it about
the learning in each
and every case.
The other thing I'd love to see
Google do is think about you
guys have thought a lot
about the learning registry
and tagging open education
resources and things like that.
I'd love to see more thought
about how assessments play
into that, because
that's what will truly
make learning content be useful
and come to life in a much more
rich way.
And I don't think we're
seeing enough innovation
in that space.
MALE SPEAKER:
Well, help me thank
Michael for showing up today.
Thank you very much.
Thank you guys for coming.